[Music]
hey what is up guys i'm pbht here and
two years ago at CES we saw a whole lot
of these 3d TVs whether you needed
glasses or there was glasses list 3d but
people didn't really like them they kind
of give you a headache they're a little
bit distracting to wear the glasses so
3d TVs just kind of slowly went away
they're not totally gone but you don't
really see 3d TV marketed nearly as much
as you did two years ago so now this
past January at CES we saw an
interesting new fad pop-up there was
obviously a lot of 4k and that is not a
fad but we also saw these curved TVs
from a bunch of manufacturers these
giant curved panels and a lot of people
have asked me questions about it people
are curious like are these legit are
they worth checking out this is a quick
video on curved TVs explain so if you've
been on this channel a while you may
recall seeing a little while ago I did a
curved smartphones explaining video but
those are much smaller displays that's a
handheld display in phones like the LG G
flex and the Samsung Galaxy round where
you can hold a curved display in your
hand and that might not change the
viewing experience a whole lot but it
definitely changes the way you touch the
phone and the way to interact with the
screen but these curved TVs are
obviously a lot bigger than your phone
and they're curved for very different
reasons than you would curve a phone
when you curved a phone you're curving
it to fit better in your hand or fit
better against your face while making a
call because that which that's what you
do with a phone when you curve a TV you
get three main differences in the
viewing experience one immersion to
Distortion and three glare now to
actually show this to you guys I'm gonna
be using this 55 inch samsung hu 9000
curved TV and yes it is actually one of
the 4k TVs shown off at CES this year so
it's perfect for this now distortion and
glare are naturally cons of what people
are concerned about when you curve a
giant TV like that is the image gonna
get distorted and is there going to be a
lot of glare from weird angles on the
bottom line is glare really isn't any
more of a problem than it is on a normal
flat TV but distortion can get a little
bit weird if you're looking at the TV
from a weird angle there's definitely a
slightly smaller viewing
radius where you want to be while
looking at the screen that doesn't mean
you can't look at it from off access and
see everything it just means that it's
gonna look a little bit weird from
slightly different angles if you're
trying to watch a movie and get the full
cinematic experience now all these TVs
have a pretty similar curve radius no
matter who you buy it from and that
measurement is the radius of the circle
this TV would make if you continued its
curve all the way around into a complete
circle so that measurement here is four
point two meters or around thirteen and
a half feet which means you'll get the
optimal viewing experience if you sit
about thirteen and a half feet away from
this TV in the center of this imaginary
circle that's where the immersion comes
in where you'll really actually notice
the curve on the TV and it changes the
viewing experience now they've made some
other changes to make this one in
particular a more immersive TV so I mean
it's a 4k TV of course more pixels makes
the image more immersive you get that's
why bezels have been getting thinner to
focus more on the content and less on
the hardware around it that's also more
immersive and I welcome all these
changes to a TV to make it more
immersive only becomes a problem though
when it's distracting 3d for example was
supposed to be more immersive but it
actually distracted you with the glasses
you had to wear or the headaches it
would cause when you're looking at it so
that's why I've faded away quickly
but I say the subtle curve here on these
TVs isn't really distracting it's as
long as you sit somewhere around that 13
foot mark you'll get a great viewing
experience in fact if you sit more than
13 feet away you're too far away and
there's really almost no point it might
as well be a flat panel because you
won't notice the curve when you sit too
far away but what's funny is when you
sit closer than 13 feet away inside that
radius it gets even more surrounding and
the TV actually seems bigger than it
really is
so really immersion tends to be that X
factor that decides what the difference
is between a curved and a flat TV but
honestly if I'm gonna tell you the truth
here you're gonna want to just see one
in person it's hard to actually judge if
you care about the curves of a TV a lot
of people just don't you know it's more
expensive first of all you're gonna have
to pay extra to get a curved TV so if
you're going to buy a curved TV check it
out in person first and check out the
larger models because the smaller ones
you're not
going to be able to tell it's curved
nearly as easily there you go guys I'm
gonna ask what do you think of curved
TVs or have you even gotten to see one
in person yet honestly the only one I've
seen in person is the one I'm showing
you today and after using it now it's
kind of weird to go back to a flat TV
just because the way it appears to you
in front of you just the angles the way
they work but let me know what you guys
think of curved TVs curved panels curved
smartphones do you even care I probably
wouldn't recommend buying a curved
smartphone at this point but it's a lot
more tempting to buy a curved TV so let
me know what you guys think thanks for
watching and I'll talk to you guys in
the very next one peace
[Music]